es werden immer mehr die nasa hat eine
neue liste mit möglichen exoplaneten
vorgestellt ein neuer rekord wurden
dabei aufgestellt nun gibt es 4000
mögliche exoplaneten zehn neue
kandidaten sind dabei die ungefähr so
groß wie die erde sind und in der
habitablen zone um einen stern kreisen
also der zone in der leben möglich ist
insgesamt gibt es damit jetzt 50
kandidaten für eine heimat von
außerirdischen leben
doch bei den exoplaneten tut sich eine
seltsame lücke auf jetzt den blick zum
seitenwechsel herzlich willkommen
doch als anfang der 90er jahre war
überhaupt nicht klar ob es überhaupt
irgendwo da draußen im weltall planeten
gibt wir wussten es einfach nicht ist
unser sonnensystem einmalig 1992 wurden
dann die ersten exoplaneten entdeckt und
heute sind es 4000 kandidaten auf der
liste der exoplaneten 50 davon könnten
außerirdisches jeden bewerber man das
ist erst der anfang der satellit etwa
hat bisher erst ein mini fällt im
sternbild schwan untersucht das aber
sehr gründlich jetzt werden neue
regionen befindet untersucht wo es gute
möglichkeiten gibt exoplaneten zu
identifizieren der katalog dürfte also
schon bald schnell wachsen und jetzt
wird die forschung auch in eine
vollkommen neue phase ein
jetzt liegen so viele exoplaneten funde
vor was sie klassifiziert werden können
wie eine biologie haben die forscher
damit begonnen die planeten in klassen
auszuzahlen und dabei wurden jetzt schon
extrem verblüffende erkenntnisse
erzählt manche klassen also größten
planeten wie gibt es besonders oft an
val kaum wir haben die wissenschaftler
keinerlei erkenntnisse darüber wie es
dazu kommt aber der reihe nach ein team
um benjamin falcon vom california
institute of technology caltech hat mit
dem keck teleskop auf hawaii 2000 sterne
mit identifizierten exoplaneten näher
untersucht dabei schließen wie auf
viele steinige supererden mit einer
masse von ungefähr er wird bis zu 15
erdmassen ab dieser größe gibt es dann
plötzlich viel weniger planeten und ab
einer größe von zwei bis drei erstmals
gibt's wieder sehr viele das sind dann
aber gasreiche mittun
das ist eine fundamentale teilung im
stammbaum der planeten analog zur
entdeckung von biologen dass säugetiere
und reptilien verschiedene zweige am
stammbaum des lebens bilden das sagt
benjamin wolken für die forscherinnen
und forscher ist diese entdeckung
ziemlich verblüffend wären eigentlich
mit einer gleichmäßigen verteilung der
größe gerechnet zwei szenarien halten
sie für wahrscheinlich dass es so nicht
gibt ab einer bestimmten größe ziehen
die gesteinsplaneten burg in wasserstoff
und helium an
dafür wich zu gasreichen minimierten
aufblähen und das zweite szenario ist
dass diese himmelskörper mit wenig gas
nicht stabil sind und dieses wenige gas
dann durch die strahlung des sterns
verlieren und wieder klar
auf jeden fall glücklich hier jetzt ein
neues fachgebiet auf und wir steigen
tiefer in die planetenforschung einen
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
hoffen dadurch auch mehr erkenntnisse
über mögliche heimatplaneten von
außerirdischen zu finden die ganz
leichter identifizieren können jetzt
sind die wissenschaftler erst mal was
auch weil unser sonnensystem so anders
ist neben der erde gibt es nur kleinere
planeten und deutlich grössere als
einen mini med tun
wir möchten wirklich gerne wissen wie
diese mysteriöse planeten beschaffen
sind und warum wir sie nicht auch in
unserem eigenen sonnensystem haben so
koautor eric kritik dura vom kreuz wenn
es neue erkenntnisse in der
planetenforschung gibt dann erfahrt ihr
es natürlich hier dafür mir hier
einfach ein abo aufs auge drücken dem
auf die glocke nicht vergessen denn nur
dann also wirklich nur dann werdet ihr
über jedes video informiert hier geht
es weiter mit der spektakulären
entdeckung von drei super erden im
tracking system einfach draufklicken
wenn es euch interessiert und ansonsten
gesang bleibt dran